hey how's it going everybody today was a
super exciting day at San Diego
comic-con 2018 we got our first trailer
for Shazam and our first trailer for
Aquaman there's a lot for us to break
down so let's just dive on in
in the beginning we get a tiny backstory
on how Arthur Curry's mother and father
meet his mother who isn't Atlanta and
washes up on the shore and his father
finds her from there they start a
romantic relationship in which Arthur is
born things to note here is that he says
that his mother was a queen she is Queen
Atlanta Queen over Atlantis and that's
why she had to return home but that
makes Arthur heir to Atlantis we then
have the scene where author as a kid and
he's getting bullied and it seems like
this is where he might discover that he
can communicate with sea animals the
animals obviously know that he's from
Atlantis because the shark tries to come
to its aid by breaking the glass and
scaring the bullies the next scene is of
Aquaman boarding a submarine then he
takes on two bad guys and the two bad
guys are actually believed to be Black
Manta and his father is actually
believed that in this scene he will kill
black mantas father and that's how Black
Manta will become a villain the next few
parts of this trailer are about
Aquaman's half-brother orme who just so
happens to be the king of Atlantis at
this time as well you see Arthur's
mother Queen atlanna
had to return to Atlantis so she could
take the throne once she returns to
Atlantis she remarries an Atlantean and
has a son this son is armed but Arthur
is the firstborn so he has the right to
the throne and that's why you hear mera
see the only way to stop warm from
declaring war on the surface world is
for author to become king they then show
a king with a trident and it's widely
believed that the majority of this movie
will be all about author trying to
regain the throne of King but in order
to do so he has to go and find this
trident you'll notice that in the
Justice League the spear that he carried
actually wasn't it tried it actually had
five heads and you can see him wildung
this same spear many times throughout
the trailer one of the coolest scenes I
think is where we see Atlantis for the
very first time to me it looks super
amazing it's bright in its color
and at the same time it looks very
modern as well this is something that
could have easily gone wrong in the
making of this movie so I'm really glad
that it looks as good as it does the
next few awesome scenes are of arm and
Aquaman fighting you can hear ORMs say
my brother has come from the surface to
challenge me for the throne again Arthur
is the firstborn so he has the right to
the throne but ormm is the current king
so it appears that although Arthur does
have the right to the throne he does
have to defeat the current king who is
armed to get the throne so one super
cool scene that we have here is Aquaman
and mera jumping into the trench the
trench are one of the Seven Kingdoms of
Atlantis and they are a evil species
they live in the deepest parts of the
ocean Aquaman himself even as a hard
time going there because the pressure is
just too much it actually hurts him the
only thing they focus on is eating is
food but it seems like they are for sure
going to be diving down into the trench
much like they do in the comics in this
movie we get a really cool look at the
fisherman king here it's really quick
but it's really cool because this is
actually one of the more evolved
kingdoms out of all the seven kingdoms
in the e W interviewed producer Peter
sanfran talked a little bit about the
fall of Atlantis into the ocean and the
separation of the Seven Kingdoms he said
that after the fall of Atlantis some
kingdoms evolved and some devolved this
is one that evolved this is a kingdom
that's primarily artistic and cerebral
with poets and philosophers and as you
can see with their evolution they
obviously look a lot more like fish they
have gills and even tails and are a lot
like merpeople one of the coolest things
about this trailer is that we actually
do see a lot of these different kingdoms
that are part of that lantus especially
at the end where we see this big
underwater battle between two of the
kingdoms we see different people riding
sharks we see different people riding
sea horses and even some people are
riding just huge sea monsters this was
all done because James Wan wanted to
kind of buff up Aquaman from riding his
seahorse storm to riding a sea dragon
that we've seen from Entertainment
Weekly and it looks crazy cool I love
how it looks with everybody riding the
sharks and
shoot seahorses and all these other
monsters of the sea I love how it all
looks and I loved how it was all filmed
James Wan wanted to really take a
different approach to it and if you look
at this trailer and you look at the
Justice League movie you can tell that
there's a difference for starters they
talk just kind of like they're not even
in water it's just normal you hear them
so easily which I love this is one thing
that James Wan really wanted to make
happen and make different than the
scenes that we saw in Justice League and
also the filming of the characters now
they weren't actually underwater when
they filmed all of these scenes they
were dry as far as them floating their
hair movement that is all just CGI and
to me it looks very good overall I think
this trailer is awesome it makes me
super excited for the movie and I
actually do have hope that these movies
like Aquaman Shazam Wonder Woman 1984 I
have hoped that they're actually going
to be a lot better than the previous DC
movies so overall I'm just super pumped
for everything especially Aquaman coming
out this December what did you all think
of the Aquaman trailer let me know all
of your thoughts in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video please give it
a thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date on everything happening with
Aquaman DC Marvel and everything
superhero thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Music]
you